while we were reporting on the forbes
400 list this year i think one of the
big takeaways was that from a political
level and also in the public discourse
is this conversation about how you know
big tech is becoming too powerful and
maybe there needs to be regulations
around it but you know so far
all this has not really had much of any
impact on how these companies are doing
financially
it's really staggering to see how you
know both
the power of big tech has increased but
also with it the fortunes of
the founders and the executives
tech's ultra rich are now in a class of
their own
the seven richest tech billionaires
together they're worth 925 billion
dollars and that is more than
the fortunes of all the billionaires in
any of the other industries that we
measured on the forbes 400. so the next
up is the finance and investments
industry
and there were 103 billionaires on our
list this year these seven tech
billionaires are worth more than
all 103 of those people in the industry
combined
we found in total 80 billionaires who
derived their wealth from technology
those 80 billionaires are worth a
collective 1.6 trillion dollars
you know really fueled by those seven
richest tech billionaires
tech is by far in a way um
the most lucrative industry among
the ultra-rich billionaires
one of the things that we found commonly
among most of these ultra-rich
billionaires is that their companies are
under siege especially by the us
government but also by you know
government agencies around the world
congress now is
debating over
whether to completely overhaul antitrust
laws and
kind of redefine them for the modern age
because
the way that these technology companies
have power is very different from
the you know monopolies of companies
from decades ago
all these
forces have you know the potential to
put major dents on companies like google
amazon
facebook
microsoft apple
but so far we haven't really seen any of
that impact on the company's
performances in the stock market people
like jeff bezos mark zuckerberg who
still have a lot of involvement with
their companies and they're for a lot of
stock with the companies
their net worths keep getting higher and
higher this is the first year that jeff
bezos or any billionaire um reached 200
billion dollars on our forbes 400 list
there are now
five american companies that have a one
trillion dollar market cap and
all five of those companies are tech
companies
it's a definitely a really interesting
crossroads right now there are you know
a lot of economic and political uh
forces that
make these coming years a really
interesting time to see you know
just how high these
tech stocks and these tech fortunes can
go
you